[Musique]
bon ben il faut que ça le soit voilà
petit noir oui dit -
avec ou sans lunettes moi je resterai
pas la lune est alors sans lunettes
bonjour lucie smit bonjour myriam encore
merci de nous accorder cet entretien à
distance vous êtes écologistes disent
présidente du think tank la fabrique
écologique depuis des semaines on entend
dire que la peau des pandémies serait le
produit du saccage de la planète
autrement dit que la crise climatique
serait à l'origine de la pandémie qu'est
ce que vous pensez vous l'écologiste de
cette thèse pour commencer alors je
pense que c'est effectivement une thèse
qui a été très présente dans le
confinement parce que en fait nous nous
sommes aperçus collectivement que
beaucoup d'épidémie que beaucoup de
virus était en fête venait des animaux
notamment des animaux sauvages quand on
regarde les chiffres par exemple il ya
environ 60 % des maladies qui sont des
zones aux comme on dit donc ils viennent
les animaux et il y en a encore plus
lorsqu'il s'agit de maladies émergentes
donc c'est clair que notre interaction
l'interaction entre nous êtres humains
et animaux
cette pandémie épidémie devenue pandémie
nous l'a fait et me ferait d'une manière
particulièrement cruel de là à dire que
c'est la nature qui se venge moi c'est
évidemment quelque chose c'est un pas
que je ne franchirai jamais d'abord
parce que je pense que c'est une
certaine manière traité de la nature
comme si elle était un être menaçants et
catastrophistes alors que j'ai confiance
j'aime la nature et je souhaite que
notre interaction avec la nature soit
totalement préservée et mais aussi parce
que je pense que ce qui est en train de
se passer nous fait mieux réaliser qu'en
que la manière dont nous agissons à
l'égard de la nature et les frontières
en fait entre l'humain et naturelles
doivent être revues en quoi cette crise
sanitaire nous renseigne sur ce qui
pourrait nous arriver je crois qu'on
apprend quelque chose à travers la les
dérèglements c'est à dire que on voit
bien que là ce virus
venu sans doute de la nature venus sans
doute des chauves souris
il se limite ils se transforment et crée
de l'incertitude
il crée de la menace de la habilité et
nous renvoie nous être humain à notre
propre vulnérabilité donc en ce sens il
montre que le monde dans lequel nous
sommes est un monde qui aujourd'hui est
davantage déréglé par le réchauffement
climatique c'est bruno latour qui a dit
ça il je crois qu'il a dit que la crise
actuelle était minuscule par rapport à
ce que sera le réchauffement climatique
je sais pas s'il faut employer ce terme
parce qu'on vit une crise d'une grande
gravité extrêmement angoissante mais en
tout cas ce qu'on mesure c'est que
l'ampleur des dérèglements qui nous
attendent qui pourrait se produire si
nous n'agissons pas sont des
dérèglements de nature à paralyser
complètement l'ancien système depuis
donc le colis de 19 à tout arrêter et la
moitié de l'humanité s'est confinée sur
la planète ce qui lui a donné à la
planète une forme de répit inédit on a
vu des animaux des canards sur le parvis
de l'opéra vous de voir la comédie
française qu'est ce qu'on est en train
d'expérimenter à travers le confinement
c'est une forme de décroissance
contrainte le conseiller on sait aussi
d'abord une prison je crois qu'il faut
le dire c'est une prison obligatoire si
nous voulons garder la vie mais il ya
quelque chose de l'ordre de regarder le
monde à travers notre fenêtre moi par
exemple j'habite avant j'ai regardé le
héron du fart de ma ville à travers les
grilles du parc c'est un petit peu comme
ce que vous visiez sur les les oiseaux
donc cette nature on la voit mais d'une
certaine manière on ne peut pas la
toucher la façon dont la nature nous est
interdite et quelque chose qui était
frappant la deuxième chose c'est que
parce qu'elle nous est interdite on se
dit bien d'habitude ont succédé des
mâles qui s'est elle a l'air d'être en
pleine forme et ça c'est une autre
source de réflexion mais ce qui est
important et dès qu'on sera des conflits
nés progressivement c'est certainement
de retrouver comme je le disais tout à
l'heure l'interaction entre la nature et
nous mêmes c'est à dire de ne pas
seulement vous savez et aimez la nature
ou les animaux à travers des
documentaires à travers des écrans à
travers de belles images la question
c'est évidemment comment nous sommes à
la nature est-ce qu'il faudra conserver
un certain nombre de comportements qu'on
a eu dans le confinement après bien sûr
évidemment là notre relation à la
consommation notre relation oui moi je
pense qu'il ya une espèce de
décroissance obligatoire toute la
question c'est de ne pas sous-estimer
les conséquences négatives
certaines personnes c'est à dire que
pour moi comment dirais-je garder les
bons gestes renoncer à certaines choses
ça ça ça n'est pas si difficile que ça
et la question que je me pose c'est
comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire pour
que ce qui est devenu impossible pendant
considérant épié bon pour la nature
comment est ce qu on pourrait tous le
conserver pour moi ce qui est essentiel
c'est qu'à l'issue du confinement sur la
question écologique on puisse imaginer
qu'un élargissement du cercle de ceux
qui se sentent concernés que dans la
société française la question de
l'écologie devienne une question pour
tous en ce sens le fait que la
convention citoyenne pour le climat est
émis par exemple ces propositions
pendant le confinement je crois que
c'est une une excellente idée une
excellente initiative au delà même du
contenu de ces propositions le dire
parce que il fallait prendre une place
dans ce débat qui ne soit pas seulement
un débat qui est un débat est ce que
c'est le terme d'élite en tout cas un
débat qui est réservé à ceux qui en ont
les moyens et en même temps et à la
crise économique
comment rendre audible ce discours
souvent de long terme de changement de
modèle nicolas hulot dit que le moment
est venu comment rendre audible cette
idée que c'est maintenant lorsqu on
risque de perdre son travail qu'on
s'inquiète pour sa santé que son
entreprise fait faillite la prise de
conscience écologique largement partagée
revanche le sentiment de pouvoir devenir
écologistes de pouvoir appliquer au fond
ce dont on ne savait où on allait mode
d'emploi en fait simplement
l'applicabilité quelque part l'aspect
microéconomie pour employer des termes
un peu technique c'est pas là et c'est
pas forcément multipliant les appels ou
les interpellations qu'on va créer cette
possibilité que tous ans participent
comment est ce qu'on peut faire moi je
crois qu'il faut bien mesurer que
l'écologie transforme le système de
responsabilité responsabilité
individuelle on assiste beaucoup là
dessus la voiture la chaudière acheter
consommer durable s'alimenter sainement
mais en sont la responsabilité
collective la question pour le
gouvernement la question pour ceux qui
ont du pouvoir plus largement que le
gouvernement les grands acteurs privés
les grands penseurs aussi pour beaucoup
de pouvoir comment est ce qu'on fait
pour que le système une responsabilité
collective parce que tous puissent
devenir écologistes moi c'est ça la
question que je me pose aujourd'hui
articuler la question sociale et les
questions écologiques canton ce qui
s'est passé et avec les gilets jaunes
c'était pas un mouvement anti écologique
moi j'ai jamais vu comme ça en revanche
c'était un mouvement de rejet de
l'injustice sociale c'est pour ça aussi
que dans les grande conférence
climatique le principe de justice
climatique et quelque chose d'aussi
essentiel pour les pays du sud par
rapport aux pays du nord mais là ce
qu'on risque de traverser c'est une
forme de deux mouvements gilet jaune
largement amplifié où la question
sociale va peut-être percuté la question
écologique est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que c'est pendant la crise
économique qu'on peut faire une action
écologique mon sentiment c'est que la
prise de conscience du côté de ceux qui
ont du pouvoir est quelque part la plus
essentielle et en ce sens qu'il ya
quelques signaux intéressants par
exemple quand bruno le maire dit qu'il
faut faire d'air france à première
compagnie environnementale aérienne
environnemental c'est un nouveau concept
je n'arrivais plus à me souvenir
l'expression ça je trouve ça très
intéressant je voyais aussi qu'il avait
écrit dans la collection gallimard la
tract de crise un petit un petit libel
pour dire qu'il fallait faire une sortie
écologique de la crise c'est la première
fois que j'entends le ministre de
l'économie se prononcer de manière aussi
claire et il se trouve que moi de très
longue date je dis qu'il faut articuler
économie et écologie de façon à des
segmenter la proche des ministères de
l'ecologie donc ça je trouve que c'est
très intéressant après tout la question
vous savez quand on parle de
greenwashing j'ai pas si elle et grimaud
chine mais en tout cas il ya beaucoup de
politique de communication la question
du passage à l'acte elle est
fondamentale qu'est ce qu'on fait et le
passage à la qui doit être ville doit
être vécue par ceux qui ont du pouvoir
par chacun d'entre nous mais aussi de
façon organisée un passage à l'acte
collectif et structurant les gouvernants
à vous parler de bruno le maire c'est
vrai qu'il vient conditionner l'aide
massive air france à des conditions de
respect de l'environnement pourrait
citer aussi les lignes aériennes
intérieures qui pourraient être
supprimés ou en tous les cas à ménager
quand ya des alternatives de train à
deux heures trente de trajet tout ça
c'est sincère ou c'est du greenwashing
le président de la république lui-même
parle de changement de modèle de
développement alors le sujet n'est pas
forcément morale ou sincérité la
question c'est plutôt comment est ce
qu'on fait pour que une intention
affichée devienne réalité c'est à dire
que comment on fait entrer les
intentions les discours dans la réalité
et en france c'est un point très
important parce qu'on est un pays de
forte culture symbolique le discours en
quelque sorte c'est comme si c'était
déjà fait alors sur l'écologie ce n'est
jamais ça donc toute la question c'est
comment on développe en france des
contre-pouvoirs mois que j'écrivais en
fait ce confinement m'a fait réfléchir
moi j'ai toujours été pour les
contre-pouvoirs la démocratie le pouvoir
des médias le pouvoir parlementaire est
en fait ce qui s'est passé pendant ce
compliment c'est que je me suis dit ouh
là là on va vraiment avoir beaucoup
besoin de contre-pouvoir pendant le
déconfinement de façon à ce que les
choses se passent non pas seulement
seulement dans les discours mais dans la
réalité donc tout le sujet c'est aussi
comment le parlement l'assemblée
nationale le sénat vont pouvoir jouer
leur rôle par rapport au gouvernement on
a senti des frustrations du côté de
certains députés donc il faut des vigies
écologique mais dès que
myriam qui vont très loin dans le détail
c'est à dire qu'il faut pas se contenter
d'être la vigie qui interpellent et qui
ensuite si je puis dire passe à la
télévision pour que quelques choses
deviennent sérieuses il faut associer
plusieurs états une forte importance
symbolique un logiciel quelque chose de
technique et la capacité aussi à mener
la guerre l'écologiste ça va devenir un
vrai champ de bataille c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui si les appels vers se
multiplient c'est aussi parce que le
medef a demandé une pause
environnementale
c'est d'ailleurs bienvenu que le fait
qu'il ait demandé une pause
environnementale et futée se soit
retrouvé assez vite dans le débat public
sinon on ne sait pas donc toute la
question de le débat public la manière
d'en parler pour en faire un enjeu qui
englobe de plus en plus de personnes la
technicité pour que les choses existent
les contre-pouvoirs et l envie d'agir l
envie d'agir elle doit se traduire à
quelle échelle est-ce que vous pensez
que l'écologie vient forcément d'en haut
vous parliez des gouvernants vous parlez
de contre-pouvoir qui doivent au fond
faire pression vous parlait même de
guerre sur ces questions d'environnement
talent est-ce qu'elle doit venir de la
société du citoyen du bas comment au
fond faire avancer cette cause là de
façon la plus efficace je pense que ce
qui est très intéressant avec le des
compliments c'est que quelque part on a
donné les clés au maire et aux élus
locaux c'est quand une première depuis
le début du quinquennat et en donnant
les clés du déconfinement je crois qu'on
ne refuse pas seulement la patate chaude
deux shows comme on donne aussi au maire
une capacité d'expérimentation auquel il
aspirait de longue date je rappelle que
dans la constitution française le droit
à l'expérimentation des collectivtés
locales ip un encadré là avec le
déconfinement écoutez je crois qu'ils
peuvent faire des choses et sur la
question des transports notamment on
voit bien que par exemple dans des
grandes villes dont paris bien sûr mais
aussi montpellier et grenoble il ya
cette idée de donner plus d'importance
au vélo est en tout cas de restreindre
l'usagé de la voiture tient à dire une
chose c'est qu'on est on vit une espèce
de paradoxe c'est à dire que les
transports en commun étaient plébiscités
par les écologistes
depuis toujours et là il faut plus
prendre les transports en commun pour
des raisons de distanciation sociale
donc moi je pense que c'est très bien le
faire plus de vélos et j'espère que ça
sera une forme de passage à l'acte de ce
que demandaient les écologistes de
longue date et d'expérimentation locale
mais n'oublions pas qu'à ne passons pas
d'une écologie à l'autre ça c'est un
point qui me semble important donc on
vit une période de transition dans
lequel au fond on invente de nouvelles
manières d'être écologiste très concrète
et on va passer progressivement un monde
d'après c'est y serait bien évidemment
c'est qu'on arrive après dans un monde
où il ya la fois du vélo et des
transports en commun et moins de
voitures il ya aussi une nouvelle donne
dans cette période c'est l'énergie et
c'est la chute drastique des prix du
baril de pétrole la grande tentation
c'est faire de la relance grise c'est à
dire au fond faire en sorte que tout le
monde bénéficie d'un retour à la voiture
avec des prix du carburant très très bas
en incitant par des primes à acheter de
nouvelles voitures vous craignez fla moi
je pense qu'il faut dire une chose sur
l'industrie cela qu'on voit bien c'est
l'automobile et l'aviation pour le plus
souffert c'est les transports pendant
pendant le confinement et je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on puisse construire de
l'écologie sur les ruines d'industrie
dont on était très fier au niveau
national et c'est d'ailleurs un des
difficultés essentielles de la france et
que sa spécialisation internationale on
peut pas dire qu'elle soit ultra
écologique on a beaucoup de grands
groupes qui se font année mans sont vus
par les écologistes classiques comme des
ennemis je dis pas qu'il n'ya pas
d'adversaire de l'écologie mais en tout
cas ne pas décréter qu'a priori le
secteur automobile c'est l'ennemi à
abattre c'est important parce que par
rapport à ce que disait sur la question
sociale l'enjeu de l'emploi il va être
beaucoup parce que mentaliser par
certains grands groupes pour demander
moins de régulation environnementale et
un monde dans lequel on mange sain et
local dans lequel on produit plus à des
milliers de kilomètres et dans lesquels
on circule de façon propre c'est pour
quand à votre ami très bientôt parce que
il ya une telle urgence que l'on ne
pourra plus et qui j'allais dire il
existe déjà dans les romans moi j'ai
créé avec d'autres des écrivains un prix
du roman d'écologie et j'observe que
l'inspiration littéraire est aujourd'hui
extrêmement puissante sur l'écologie on
nous disait que c'était un truc des
américains de nature writing non c'est
quelque chose qui existe en france
notamment avec des premiers romanciers
et je crois que
les romands nous disent déjà dans leur
imaginaire ce que nous allons devenir
bientôt donc moi j'y crois c'est pas
cool 6 mai
[Musique]